all right the house comes back from
Summer recess one week from today and
that means that the investigations into
the Biden family well Syndicate or if
you're from Bolton County Enterprise
that means it's about to ramp up house
oversight committee they just subpoenaed
the Department of Homeland Security over
Secret Service documents that could help
explain why Hunter Biden was allegedly
tipped off about a forthcoming FBI
interrogation once he got the warning
that interview never happened and don't
forget we also learned that a justice
department official met with the IRS
whistleblower Gary shapley's attorneys
and seem to be interested in the
allegations before immediately turning
around and talking to Hunter's attorneys
which resulted in them quickly cutting
that sweetheart deal with Hunter
meanwhile the White House is reportedly
developing a war room to deal with the
Fallout from these investigations which
could ultimately result with an
impeachment inquiry and then into an
impeachment we reached out to the DHS
for comment on coma subpoena and on
background BR an official told us that
they're working on Cora's request and
have never obstructed or withheld a
response okay here we now with the
preview of what can be expected next
week and Beyond house Judiciary
Committee chairman Jim Jordan house
oversight committee chair James comr can
you explain why this doj official James
comr met with the attorney for Gary
shapley before he testified before
Congress in light of the letter that Mr
shapley said had information to give
Congress which is oversight which is
your committee which is of course uh uh
other committees as well can you explain
the purpose of that and then turning
around immediately thereafter and going
right to to Hunter Biden's attorneys uh
that would seem like they tipped them
off to
me absolutely that's what it looks like
and that's what happened and we have
instance after instance throughout this
whole investigation to where we've
uncovered more information about where
the IRS investigation into Hunter Biden
which as we've heard from the IRS
whistleblowers was leading directly to
Joe Biden was obstructed and I can tell
you from uh my experience over the past
nine months leading this investigation
of Biden's uh all the influence pedaling
schemes that we've been obstructed at
every turn not only by the Biden
attorneys but also by the Department of
Justice by Homeland Security now we've
been obstructed by the media we've been
obstructed by democrats the house
oversight committee the FBI and the list
goes on and on but we're still able to
produce evidence new evidence every week
that no one knew beforehand and I
believe all this evidence that we've
gathered we're finally starting to piece
it together and put together a timeline
and what we're finding is very
concerning about the current president
of the United States let me let me get
to you Jim Jordan can you explain uh
that and and this gets to the heart of
your investigation in in the Judiciary
Committee and that is whether or not the
FBI and doj are politicized and whether
they're weaponized that sounds an awful
like a lot like to me the doj is
weaponized and they're using the FBI and
now even Secret
Service yeah the same us attorney who
tipped off the Secret Service the same
us attorney's office who talked to Gary
schaper's uh lawyer is the same us
attorney's office who designed the
sweetheart deal that was declined by the
judge that's the same guy that Merrick
Garland made the special counsel so of
course the fix is in the white is
getting all ready cuz they know what's
likely to happen later this month the
speaker's been clear about this if we
need to go to an impeachment inquiry
phase of our oversight work we will do
that they're getting ready but we're
going to come at this from all angles Mr
comr today subpoena documents and
individuals from DHS and the Secret
Service chairman Smith has subpoenaed
individuals from the IRS who were part
of the investigation into Hunter Biden
we have subpoenaed individuals from the
FBI who were part of the investigation
we want them in for depositions so we're
coming at this from three sides Ides to
get the facts for the country so we know
whether we need to go to impeachment
inquiry but it is looking like more and
more every day we need to go to that
phase of our oversight work where do you
see this go in Jim Jordan I mean the
obstruction has been in plain sight the
1023 form well we now know why they
didn't want to hand that over uh that
earlier before that it was the
suspicious activity reports now it's you
know now we can't get the 5,400 emails
under pseudonyms cuz the National
Archives and record associate you know
Nar is not handing over the information
is anybody going to cooperate with what
is the rightful role of Congress called
oversight of
government well this is where the
impeachment inquiry phase of
Investigation I think becomes important
and speaker McCarthy has talked about
this once you actually pass a resolution
that says we're in that phase of
oversight uh work our constitutional
Duty then the courts have been much more
willing when you have to go to court to
get the information that Mr comr talked
about were trying to get the courts have
been much more willing to say hey this
is a constitutional duty of the house
the House of Representatives if in fact
they're doing impeachment you need to
provide those documents and those
individuals for the depositions that
they ask for so that's why that is
significant and again I think the
evidence is pointing us clearly in that
direction we'll get back we'll discuss
it as a conference and see if we have
that resolution vote and we move forward
as the speaker has indicated do you
believe that that resolution vote will
pass James
comr I do and I think that uh I've been
in conversation with a lot of the
moderate members who obviously for
various reasons have been concerned
about this but the evidence is
overwhelming and the fact that the White
House announced today they're creating a
war room uh as opposed to cooperating
with our investigation if Joe Biden's
completely innocent if he's running the
most transparent Administration in
history like he said if he's been
completely honest with the American
people about his knowledge and
involvement in his family Shady business
schemes then why won't they just comply
with our request we haven't requested
anything that I think anyone would say
is out of the ordinary this is a
credible investigation uh everything
that we have made public is new
information that no one knew before
we've caught Joe Biden in countless lies
about his knowledge and involvement in
his family Shady business schemes and
this I think Sean even members of the
moderate wing of our party are realizing
this could potentially be the biggest
political scandal in my adult lifetime
we have a president who has uh evidence
that his family's taken over $20 million
from foreign Nationals we have sworn
testimony and emails that show that the
president was doing favors in exchange
for this money his family is receiving
this is very serious we need to get all
the facts we've been producing evidence
we're at some roadblocks now with this
Administration this impeachment inquiry
will help us get all the evidence so the
American people can know once and for
all exactly what Joe Biden did and when
he did it the Biden the Joe Biden lies
the sheer amount of money countries like
China Russia uh Kazakhstan Ukraine
Romania Mexico and and many more Jim
Jordan uh the money going to a family
with no experience at all uh Joe having
dinners with some of these bit business
partners according to Deon Archer over
20 phone calls that he's aware of with
the business partners that he said he
never spoke to his son about or his
brother about or anybody for that matter
wow uh why isn't every single newscast
leading with this story in the
country you know you would think they
would but we know how the leftwing
Legacy Media operates but I do think
more and more of them are beginning to
pick it up some of the mainstream press
but we know you guys have got the truth
you guys are giving the truth to the
American people and God bless you for
doing it all right well thank you guys
what you're doing Jim Jordan James comr
we appreciate it we'll keep on the story
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else